he's averaging about 35 points those
last three minutes and that has been
huge
yeah one of the things Terry Stotts is
bein little choked up ruffles down the
line
in the year when beyond raid was out the
show and go
the open shooter Baines picks on the
triple and the sun's uh you know want to
play spoiler but also want to still stay
credible finding the three-point range
early so just to kind of start this
doctor his head coach shorter in the
absence of T on rate fades with a step
back to read lock fit man was a guard
like step back I mean I was a good four
and a half foot step back to get behind
this strike well if he is the game with
eighteen three points in time aggregate
certainly qualify it as a bad thing but
firing supper for me
keep points shooting party he is now
four of seven upon the season looking
for a career take the steam out of his
Blazers and their euphoria book finds
the open lane kicks it corner three on
the way for banks boom goes boom from
the court what was he gonna do but why
Devin Booker look so perplexed Rubio
whips a pass
feeding bein straight away
I guess he gets that Mulligan his
friends jr. was a big part of the
blazers getting back in this bands
hunting another triple get six gets a
switch step back three on the way
halfway in and out Bane's
we just do a little bit everything
tonight the reason with the ball denial
on Booker pork get some separation won't
get it
Tippin
we'll go down
[Applause]
they're on the brother kitchen
in the waiver thing
[Applause]